what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob and I
thought it'd be kind of cool to have a
conversation about the god killer armor
and like Avengers 4 because I really
hope we get to see it right like I mean
I think it'd be awesome to be able to
see Iron Man's God killer ok so there's
two types there's two types of god
killer armor they both have the same
name but they serve two distinctly
different purposes in fact one of them
is not even a piece of armor that Tony
Stark made but I think it's actually
cooler but the one that Tony Stark made
is the Iron Man model 45 and I want to
say that it's based on the idea of the
model 42 because I did a whole video on
these things you think I'd remember um I
think it was based on the model 42 and
then like the modular suit the modular
suit was one that allowed him to like
add things onto it as he wanted to you
as opposed to just being like a standard
standalone armor it could be but he
could also add stuff on to it but the
model 45 came in bindas guardians of the
galaxy and in fact him joining the
guardians and forming the mana the model
45 the mark 45 that actually came out of
the first god-killer armor story we look
at without here in a second so the idea
was that this this armors pretty
straightforward it's really not that
special to be honest as far as I'm aware
it's really not that special it's pretty
basic in comparison to like the other I
guess in relation to the other models it
does allow for like interplanetary
travel and like traveling at Mach 10 but
aside from that and maybe like a couple
of enhanced weapons it's not really that
special it's basically designed to be
like his his latest version of the Iron
Man armor at the time that also allows
him to travel through space but it was
cool to see him as part of the guardians
of the galaxy that was a pretty cool
thing I've actually got that whole run
of videos on my channel if you want to
check it out I'll have the link down in
the description but still like for me
that the coolest version of the god
killer armor is actually the one that
was created by the aspirins so your
Marvel Comics as most everybody knows by
now you have the Celestials right like
you've got all these different semesters
you have the Celestra who's the one
above all not to be confused with the
actual one above all they both share the
same name but the actual one above all
is the god of Marvel and then like the
one - above - all - you know whatever
that's the head celestial basically
you've got like Aaron the judge you have
damn you've got the oh you got the
dreaming Celeste Joe I think the
dreaming Celeste sure was super powerful
I can't remember it was something like
the dreamy celestial I think was ousted
by the other Celestials and can find the
earth and then the x-men found it I
don't remember I remember a whole lot
about the dreaming celestial I need to
look into that um that's one of those
things I don't know I don't know a whole
lot about but still anyway so so
everybody knows about the Celestials
okay so the way this worked is you you
know and we're gonna go full-on into the
origin of the universe but basically you
had two warring groups of the Celestials
on one side you had those who were
deemed to be like faithful to the
universe basically and then you had the
ones who just went off and did their own
thing the ones who were faithful meaning
they actually sought permission from the
universe to see whether or not they
could create life those were called the
aspirants and then the the ones who
weren't faithful and did their own
things they were just called Celestials
what ended up happening is a war between
these two factions broke out when the
first universe came into existence and
then the war was so powerful it
destroyed the first universe and the
fractions I guess the little shattered
pieces of that first universe formed the
first multiverse and then they were just
born and killed and born and killed in
their soul and so I guess we did explain
the origin I guess we didn't go full-on
in the universe but that's that's the
idea in every single iteration of the
multiverse that's ever existed in Marvel
Comics the aspirants and the Celestials
have always gone to war now in the main
Marvel Universe the really the most
recent war between the two of them and
when I say recent I mean like billions
of years ago the most recent war between
the Astra's and the Celestials saw these
Celestials I'm sorry saw the aspirants
losing and so what they ended up doing
is they created something called a God
killer armor and it was armored that
stands like 2,000 feet tall or something
stupid like that and it was armor that
was designed for the purpose or it was
really like a giant mechanized suit
there was design for the purpose of
essentially just like allowing the
aspirants to control it and then destroy
Celestials and it did it killed a lot of
Celestials ultimately the Celestials
ended up destroying what was left of the
aspirants anyway so it didn't really
matter
and so the god killer armor just sat
unused for like billions of years and so
when you fast-forward to the modern day
what you basically end up finding out is
there was there was a guy called
recorder 451 and the recorders and
Marvel Comics are basically just robotic
beings that exist to go out into the
universe and just Chronicle things and
they're created by what are called
those aren't super super important but
they're called they're created by the
ridge elion and it's basically just
gotten to the universe catalog
everything report back and then we'll
send you back out again and that's
basically how that whole thing works one
of the recorders 451 had kind of
developed a personality of its own even
though it wasn't supposed to and came to
the realization that like humanity will
one day uh sure in an era of peace but
there are always threats to earth
there's always beings out there that
want to destroy earth and I think that
at the time a story was being written by
Karen Gillan I think even like kind of
said look like there are powers that
will come for you that will want to
destroy the Shiar Empire the crea the
scrolls whatever they're gonna want to
obliterate you and so like you Tony
Stark need a piece of tech that will
allow you to like keep these threats at
bay and so what ended up happening is
recorder 451 when and basically modify
the genes of the first child at Howard a
Maria start we're gonna have and that
that resulted in our know I think
actually I think he crew he artificially
created our know in the womb of Maria
Stark Howard Stark modified the genes
who they didn't trust recorder 451 and
then that resulted in our know who was
super smart but paralyzed from the neck
down and then they adopted Tony Stark
and passed him off as their son and hid
or no away so we're so the recorder
would never learn about it so they just
said well Tony Stark's the one Sonny
Tarkas our son so technically speaking
in Marvel Comics Tony Stark is not
actually the biological son of Howard a
Maria Stark and if you're actually
really curious about that cuz this is a
really really cool story here in
Guillen's
Iron Man run covers all that just Google
search
Kieron Gillen like kie ro n GI ll Yen
iron Iron Man and like that will give
you that whole arc and then you go into
International Iron Man which is actually
Tony Stark's search for his biological
mother which is a really really cool
story it's pretty it's like seven issues
it's not super long but it's really
really cool anyway because of the fact
that that record of 451 believed that
Tony Stark was a child that he basically
engineered the child was engineered with
a capacity to be able to wield this
godlike machine this godlike suit of
armor and then pilot it back to earth
ultimately recorder found out that Tony
Stark wasn't the actual child he
engineered and that was the end of that
but it was it was cool because it's this
a master suit of armor it's designed to
list it to be able to use
enough energy to like destroy literal
gods and here's the reason why I think
that might happen so in the MCU we know
that Tony Stark wouldn't be able to
build something like that
within a reasonable time frame I mean
you're talking about a suit of armor
that's 2,000 feet tall in the comic like
it's it's it's it's massive
there was an entire corridors that like
Tony Stark goes running down or flying
down because it's so huge in size
because of this in the in the MCU we
know the Celestials existed and we know
that like eon was one of the Celestials
we don't know anything else about them
all we know is that at some point along
the line I think it was Aaron the judge
usually use the Power Stone to like
destroy all life on a planet done and
then like Eon is a celestial and that's
it that's that's all we have
like they possess the Infinity stones at
some point you could easily like tie all
those strings together right I mean you
can basically say okay with the
Celestials or I'm sorry with the
god-killer armor like it was a war that
broke out with the Celestials between
the Celestials that may be a rogue
faction or something like that who knows
but the god killer armor was created for
the purpose of destroying the Celestials
and maybe it did maybe it destroyed
almost all of them except for Aeon or
pretty much all of them except for Aeon
and that's why he's the only one we've
seen all the other ones are dead and
this suit of armor is just sitting on a
planet on the other side of the cosmos
waiting to be found and you know by
whatever man and whatever means with
Rochard McCune or something like that
Tony Stark goes on this crusade to find
some find like recruits or whatever and
they stumble across the god killer armor
now the question asked here is would the
god killer armor be powerful enough to
destroy Thanos with the full power of
the Infinity Gauntlet probably not but
just because it wouldn't be powerful
enough doesn't mean we wouldn't see it I
mean this is just a theory I've got no
evidence to support this I mean there's
there's no reason to believe that I'm
I'm right here but I do think it would
be cool to have like this massive suit
of armor that's 2,000 feet tall this
piloted by Tony Stark and it's just like
you know staving off we're trying to
assault trying to assault an or
something like that because when I think
of Avengers 4 and I think of like this
final battle with a nose it's very easy
to look at it and to say okay so we're
basically gonna have a fist fight we're
gonna have more of what we saw in
infinity war but I don't think we will
you know at least I hope we don't I hope
we see like some crazy levels of stuff
just like some some bonkers things like
throwing planets at him or they didn't
infinity got my dad I don't know if they
a lot of people are taking more of like
a cynical approach with I'm not gonna do
that they don't know how to make a good
movie whatever like I don't know if
they're if they're if they're gonna go
that route but still like I think it
would be cool then I think it would be
really really interesting to see like
this godly armor just like like facing
off against a nose like this 2,000 foot
tall suit of armor like facing off
against Stannis and that was just like
destroys it like with like one swing of
his hand just like destroys the armor in
its entirety I mean that would just be
awesome awesome in size but still if we
were gonna see like a god killer suit of
armor I would wager we'll probably see
the one from Brian Michael Bendis as
guardians of the galaxy just because now
you basically have rocket and and nebula
and Tony Stark and and they're gonna go
and do their own thing most likely I
mean I don't know I don't really see how
the how they you know I see him making a
suit of armor that would allow him to
travel through space just because space
is now a more tangible thing than it was
before that's kind of the cool thing
about infinity war is before it was like
okay so you have the guardians of the
galaxy and then you have the Avengers
but because they never crossed over they
almost felt distinctly different and so
space didn't really feel like a tangible
relatable thing it just kind of felt
like a thing that was there but then
when you're watching the events of
infinity war unfold you're just like
Dave there one other planets like you
this is crazy and and it gets really
really interesting and it gets really
cool so yeah I'm pretty excited to see
how all this on how this whole thing
unfolds but nonetheless uh yeah let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments section if you guys want to see
like the god Killer armor and let me
know which one you want to see if you
want to see like the aspirant god killer
armor or the ironman god killer armor
because he uses both so i'm curious to
see which one you guys you guys want to
see but without being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end and
yeah i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]